it's the first ps+ extra and premium
update of the Year I'll show you
gameplay from all the games coming to
the service and it's your job to decide
what to play I'm Adam hello there please
leave me a like to support this series
let's do this starting with ps+ extra
this great month begins with a
Borderlands game Tiny Tina's wonderlands
the iconic loter shooter with so many
gun variations has been adapted into a
DND board game by the dungeon master
tiny ntina we progress through her
imagination as anything she says becomes
reality in this world luckily we also
have new abilities as each of our former
Vault Hunters is given a new class to
master from the frost infused Berserker
to the gr born who uses dark magic and
even a spawn Warden who spews out a
toxic mushroom companion we also have
new abilities and upgrades thanks to a
series of skill trees as always
Borderlands games are best played with
friends online or in split screen couch
Co-op so call a friend maybe this
version of Tiny Tina's wonderlands is
the next level Edition which adds the
PS5 version and the dragon lord pack
featuring a ton of new weapons next we
have the sublime Resident Evil 2 remake
from 2019 I honestly believe this is the
best Resident Evil game ever made set in
third person we play as Leon and CLA to
combat trained survivors of a zombie
outbreak now in Raccoon City each
character has their own version of event
to play through giving Resident Evil 2
some great replayability as the duo
tried to escape the city before the
military nuke it one of the greatest
aspects of re2 is the everpresent bad
guy Mr X the Fedora wearing antagonist
cannot be beaten and is constantly on
the hunt for you the levels of tension
added to the early game due to him being
here is something you must experience
after completing the campaign there are
also ghost survivors to play as to see
how they got away from Raccoon City AR
to remake is in my list of the top five
games ever made I hope you give it a go
or maybe jump back in if you haven't
played for a few years here's a change
of pace hard space Ship Breaker a game
about being a salvage technician in
space we are armed with a laser cutter
in first-person perspective and
systematically cut the best parts out of
an old ship and sell them for cash
surprisingly I found this game quite
zen-like like power wash simulator but
as the difficulty heightens you'll find
yourself carefully cutting away sections
that could explode at any moment taking
down huge parts of your potential profit
weekly challenges add variation and new
ways to play the game and for people who
don't like time limits use the open
shift mode to play at your own speed
hard space ship Breakers comes to ps+
extra on January 16th this month's
sports game is Sessions Skate Sim and
it's exactly what it says on the tin an
open-ended skateboarding experience with
a scoring system to push you to be more
creative and unique with your skills
sessions allows us to change the map on
the Fly adding higher rails and adapting
half pipes to Perfect The Run of your
dreams and the replay mode is also a
great touch allowing players to record
epic moments with a custom camera with
the recent Lego fortnite mode reminding
many gamers that Lego is in fact cool
comes Lego City Undercover on the PS4
playing as Chase McCain a police officer
who is undercover in this city and we
must track down Rex Fury these guys have
such great names this Lego open world
has 20 unique districts to investigate
and so many Collectibles you'll have
nightmares with Co-op split screen
supported and that weird humor that only
Lego can get away with Lego City
Undercover is enjoyable at all ages a
different type of open world is found in
Just Cause 3 playing as the amazing Rico
Rodriguez with his trusty wing suit we
are here to destabilize the fictional
country of Michi forcing the dictator
out of hiding but before that happens
there's a Sandbox of opportunities to
experience from parachuting to using a
grapple hook and blowing up anything
that takes your fancy the destruction in
Just Cause 3 is impressive especially as
it's physics based and we have some
strange things at our disposal I mean
you can attach balloons to cows and
watch them float away Just Cause 3 is a
PS4 game from 2015 so don't expect too
much Freedom before the game implodes
the RPG for the month is vampire the
Masquerade swan song a narrative focused
RPG in fact we play as three different
vampires as we decide how much they
align to being a human or give in to
their inner vampire as we are constantly
around humans keeping yourself hidden
becomes key to progression we are then
presented with moral decisions that
start off easy to know the right answer
but over time everything becomes gray
there's no real right answer which means
every player should have a unique
playthrough vampire the Masquerade swans
song released 2 years ago to mixed
reviews surviving the aftermath is a
city Builder set in the apocalypse
making it also a survival game set on a
procedurally generated ated map we build
a basic settlement for our survivors and
send them out to scavenge for resources
but we can never be certain what will
happen next as numerous Random
Encounters can be triggered testing your
skills as a town leader if successful
new technology can be found resulting in
new buildings and new possibilities but
you should know you are not the only
ones creating a community out here and
finally on extra this month Shadow
tactics Blades of the shun and get this
it's a real-time stealth Focus tactics
game setting Feud Japan a warlord is
taking over jeopardizing the entire
country we turn to the Samurai and bring
them all to Justice we are in control of
what the samurai does and must
infiltrate Mighty castles and hidden
camps strategy is incredibly important
in Shadow tactics as this game is not
very forgiving concentration is most
definitely needed hey a new section of
the video my pick for the month a game
you may have missed on the service that
I think now is the perfect time to play
and this month it's Final Fantasy 7 7
remake the second part in that trilogy
is releasing next month which means your
social media will be packed with it so
now is a great time to play the iconic
RPG remake on both PS4 or PS5 and the
PS5 version has the DLC included in the
integrade version this Final Fantasy
removed the turn-based combat and
switched to real time and has some of
the most compelling characters in recent
memory especially my girl Jesse Final
Fantasy 7 is still on ps+ and if you're
not sure what to play this month I
highly recommend it it's now the part of
the video where games are removed from
the catalog next week 10 games are
leaving we'll see Devil May Cry and its
special edition depart as well as it
takes two one of the best couch co-op
games ever made and back for blood and
unofficial followup to the great Left
for Dead games Jet the far Shore leaves
in January as does omno the missing JJ
mcfield and the island of memories
mitsugi kamway haai sorry for that
pronunciation pillars of Eternity 2 and
the strangely brilliant snowrunner you
have until January 16th to have your
wicked way with these games and then
they become locked out even if you have
them downloaded by the way omno has a
platinum trophy you can get naturally in
about 3 and 1/2 hours if you're New
Year's resolution was to get more
Platinum trophies this year oky doie
over to ps+ premium coming to premium
and Deluxe is Star Wars episode one The
Phantom Menace on the OG PS1 the game
attempted to implement a nonlinear
storyline and added extra content not
seen in the movies surprisingly this is
mainly a puzzle game it was great back
then I wonder if it's still great now
next street fighters 30th Anniversary
Collection which brings 12 Street
Fighter games to the service and now you
know why the thumbnail says 25 games the
legendary oneon-one fighter spans the OG
Street Fighter game which became the
much loved Street Fighter 2 and all the
way through the Alpha Series blending
both the arcade editions with the home
release standards if you played one of
these Street Fighter games each month
you'd still be playing this series in a
year from now wow this month we have the
Final Fantasy Adventure spin-off series
known as Mana in particular Legend of
mana and Secret of Mana the action RPG
setting a high fantasy world which used
to be compared to Zelda the usual
formula is controlling a group of three
Heroes either preventing an Empire from
falling or subduing an evil entity
usually found in a flying fortress the
16-bit era is well represented this
month and finally we have rally cross on
the PS1 for it's time it was quite
revolutionary with the sand and mud
particles representing realism yes we
really thought this looked lifelike back
then h a great little rally racer with
20 cars to race through a competitive
season and tournaments so that's our
month what do you recommend what are you
playing my name's Adam thank you for
sticking around till the end I'll see
you next
time